what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
within the nation of Canada near the
Alberta Saskatchewan provincial border
resides a small town known as cold Lake
founded in 1790 through the merging of
grant's inner cold lay proper and medley
by 1883 this community was met with the
birth of James Howlett the product of an
affair between Elizabeth Holland and
Thomas Logan the estate's ground keeper
James was born a sickly child appearing
frail and prone to electric attacks
raised by his grandfather due to his
mother's mental instability and his
father's busy life James early days in
the estate were rife with abuse
according to his grandfather the
weakness of James came from a lack of
discipline and by imposing his own
abusive practices looked to build his
grandson into a man of courage strength
the conviction indeed James only true
reprieve from his harsh life came in the
form of his friends Rose O'Hara and dog
assigned to look after him at the
request of Jamie's mother and father
Rose was a warm and welcome reprieve
from the abusive nature of his
grandfather and so going into their
younger years something akin to a
romance blossomed between the two a
development which did not go unnoticed
the legitimate son of Thomas Logan dog
had received his nickname owing to the
treatment he received from his father
who viewed him as more of an animal than
a son beating him fiercely at almost
every opportunity the life of dog was
one of torment while he'd also developed
feelings for Rose the combination of
this unrequited love and his inability
to adequately express himself left him
feeling neglected ignored and filled
with bitter jealousy forcing himself on
Rose in an effort to demonstrate his
affection the actions of dog were
reported by James and after killing
James puppy in retaliation both dog and
his father Thomas Logan were exiled from
the estate left to survive without work
in the harsh environment of the Canadian
wilderness
Thomas grew filled with anger and
vengeance arming himself with a shotgun
and invading the Hallett estate Thomas
and dog looked to leave the wilderness
for a better life and take Elizabeth out
with them
in an effort to stop the kidnapping John
Howland was killed by Thomas as James
enter the room and witnessing the
harrowing scene unfold something snapped
in the mind of James and as he fell into
an animalistic state slaughter Thomas
with his bone claws and scarred the face
of dog after which James was exiled from
the estate by his mother who took her
own life and looking to forward his own
way in the world left everything but
rose behind finding themselves taking up
work in a British Columbia stone quarry
within the Yukon Territories of Canada
james began assuming the identity of
logan finding his body growing as he
inner puberty Logan's changes included
developing a healthy and ferocious
personality as well as enhanced agility
strength and heightened senses gaining
the respect of his fellow miners due to
his work ethic in February of 1907 the
life of Logan had finally caught up to
her trucking down both Logan and rose to
the quarry dog had looked to take his
revenge for the death of his father in
the scar on his face confronting Logan
and with the two engaging in a fierce
battle
Logan gained the upper hand and knocked
dog unconscious continuing to kill him
with his bone claws Rose sought to
prevent this knowing the emotional toll
it would take but in his enraged state
Logan impaled rose and driven by grief
and heartache fled to quarry running as
far as he could into the depths of the
Canadian wilderness where he cast aside
his humanity and threw in with a pack of
wolves on the other side of the world
Nathaniel Essex now calling himself mr.
sinister had begun using his unnaturally
long lifespan as a means to continue his
research into the fledgling Raj the
mutant population learning of a man in
the Canadian wilderness whose strength
speed agility senses and healing factor
had become something of legend
sinister set loose a genetically
modified polar bear slaughtering the
wolves and Logan's absence upon his
return Logan and the bear mortally
wounded one another in a fierce battle
and recovering due to his healing factor
Logan went forward once again completely
alone
following this Logan spent the next
seven years as a vagrant wandering from
town to town throughout Canada in the
United States occasionally taking up
work and continually falling in and out
of love all the while completely unaware
that he was being watched by dangerous
eyes a being of old born during
prehistoric times
Romulus stood is one of the world's most
dangerous and oldest men having spent
his life as a ruler of the Roman Empire
a warlord a conqueror and a master
manipulator Romulus watched as the early
life of Logan unfolded and saw him as
someone who could be molded into a
highly deadly weapon thus when Logan had
settled down in the Canadian Rockies
with silver fox a member of the
Blackfoot Native American tribe Romulus
dispatched Sabretooth to kill her on
Logan's birthday discovering that
happiness had eluded him yet again Logan
descended into madness and after a
lengthy battle between the two left his
nemesis behind believing him dead but
being unaware of Sabretooth healing
factor turning his sights to exploration
for the next several decades Logan
roamed the world encountering heroes and
villains sometimes fighting and
sometimes saving them all the while
being manipulated by Romulus in Kansas
City he encounter mystique in her band
of scam artists and New York he met Eric
Brooks a young vampire hunter in Spain
he fought as part of their civil war in
Japan he fought the hand and in Russia
he was trained under Harris Romanov an
agent of Romulus where he learned the
art of espionage and so by 1941
following u.s. involvement in World War
two both Logan and the newly created
Captain America fought side-by-side in
their efforts to thwart the merging of
the hand and Baron von strucker's Hydra
pulled away from his assignment at the
orders of Romulus and reassigned to
infiltrate Japan with his location and
mission passed by Romulus to the
Japanese government Logan was quickly
apprehended and under the direction of
Romulus was taken to a prison camp near
the city of Hiroshima there he found a
friend in a cellmate lieutenant Ethan
Warren unaware that Ethan was an agent
of Romulus who continued his campaign as
tripping Logan of everything he loved
when the two escaped and met a Japanese
woman named Atsuko with whom Wolverine
had settled down ethan returned and
murdered the girl after which Hiroshima
was met with the results of the
Manhattan
once again leaving Logan in isolation by
1961 with the United States in the midst
of the Cold War with the Soviet Union
Chiang a longtime friend of Logan and
business partner for Landau Luckman and
lake maintained Logan's business
ventures while Logan in turn carried out
missions for the firm in eliminating
corporate rivals working largely in
Ottawa Calgary South America imagine
poor Romulus had Logan recruited by the
Central Intelligence Agency and began
wiping his mind and implanting false
memories going forward remembering only
what Romulus allowed him to Logan had no
recollection of his previous romantic
interests or his children and instead
functioned as a cold-blooded field agent
engaging in a series of wet work
missions as part of Team X alongside
Sabretooth Silver Fox
Kestrel Mastodon and maverick the role
of team act served as part of a greater
unit known as weapons plus
the brainchild of Romulus and developed
by John Sablan using notes for mr.
sinister weapons Plus served as an
answer to the question of the mutant
threat and the long arm of Project
wide-awake with the rise of the mutant
population giving way to fears of a war
with humanity the US government covertly
began looking for methods to contain and
control the mutant threat as such
weapons plus itself dated as far back as
weapon one with Captain America however
with the perceived death of Steve Rogers
weapons two through nine were initiated
and included bonding cybernetics to both
humans and animals as well as the study
of mutant abilities and their various
countermeasures to this end while Team X
eliminated political threats as mandated
by its charter with in the CIA's black
ops division it also had multiple
run-ins with mutants of interest to the
federal government including the young
Charles Xavier and Erik Lehnsherr
becoming one of the most successful
feared and deadliest groups in the
intelligence community by 1967 and for
reasons that were never made clear Team
X was banded by the CIA under the
direction of Romulus believing that the
events of his life had been
systematically engineered Logan went
underground with little or no
information being available on what he
did during that time and so by 1972
Logan had resurfaced in Canada is part
of Department K as the covert Special
Branch of Canada's Ministry of Defense
Department K was based out of Ottawa and
shared a number of joint missions with
the CIA involving Neil Langham special
agent Nick Fury US Air Force pilot Carol
Danvers and CIA agents Richard and Mary
Parker finally locating Logan during a
mission
Romulus had Logan drug with Thorazine
beaten and taken to a Weapon X facility
under the control of doctors Abraham
Cornelius Carol Hines and true and
Hudson
experiencing sensory deprivation mental
reprogramming and having adamantium
bonded to his skeleton the once morally
questionable man was transformed into a
murderous killing machine and given the
codename Wolverine however where Romulus
intended to use Logan as a mercenary for
hire
Wolverine broke free of his programming
and killed everyone in the Weapon X
facility with the exception of Malcolm
Colcord Carol Hines true at Hudson and
Abraham Cornelius
after which he left the facility and
vanished into the Canadian wilderness
[Music]
I think that the origin that you gave
Wolverine is one of the most brilliant
origins ever and one of the most
provocative and mystifying and it kept
the readers on the edge of the seat spur
I don't know how many years wondering
how did it happen what happened up in
Tanana and I mean it was just wonderful
the way Wolverine almost single-handedly
kept people fascinated by that book
[Music]